This sock is knit from
the heel up to the cuff.
We'll start by working
an open caston for the heel.
We'll be joining these open stitches
to the leg later, so cast
on with waist yarn and ravel cord.
Next, we'll start shaping
the heel with short row shaping.
Set your carriage to hold
in both directions.
Now, following the pattern on the carriage
side, I'm putting one needle into hold
position and I'll knit across
again on the carriage side.
Put a needle into hold
position and knit across.
Now, this is automatic
wrap short row shaping.
Just keep repeating this
according to your pattern.
Now, if this shaping is new to you,
please study the tutorials that are
included with this course.
Also, please practice this technique
before you start knitting your socks.
When the short rows decreases are
complete, I'll shortrow increase until all
the needles are back
into working position.
Now that the heel is finished,
I'll knit the sole indicated
by the letter C on the diagram.
This is the bottom of the foot.
When that knitting is complete,
we'll knit the toe.
Again, we're going to use
short row shaping.
But this time, notice that I'm using.
A manual wrap method.
The needles are pulled out into hold
on the opposite side of the carriage,
and then the yarn is manually
wrapped to prevent holes.
These two methods are explored
in a tutorial in this course under
the heel and toe technique section.
Now, if all of this is new to you,
please watch, learn and practice both
automatic and manual short rows
shaping and decide which you prefer.
Now that the toe is done,
we'll knit the instep of the sock.
This is a great place to get creative
with cables or lace or color work.
In this example,
I put stripes on the instep only.
It's a great way to incorporate
little bits of yarn.
Now, here's the fun part.
Remember those live stitches at the heel?
We're going to turn the knitting so that
the pearl side of that heel is facing us.
And then hang those live
stitches on the machine.
Just take care that you
don't twist the sock.
Take a minute to make sure
you can rehang this, either on the left
or the right side of the work.
It really doesn't matter.
We're just joining the heel to the.
Leg at this point, eliminating a seam.
Now notice that I've doubled up
the seaming stitches at the join here.
This will make seaming
neater at that join point.
Once all the stitches are on the machine,
continue to knit the leg in the stitch
pattern of your choice
knitting pattern instructs you to knit
a few rows plain for a transition.
And at that point, feel free to transfer
stitches to the river for a ribbed leg or
remove the knitting
on hand knitting needles.
To hand knit some ribbing.
I chose to knit a plain
leg with a rolled edge.
I worked the figure eight
bind off for lots of stitch.
Except for the finishing my socks.
Done.